premier trophée qu'on voulait décerné
celle au profit de la meilleure d'arca
de l'année la meilleure rigolade de
l'année est la meilleure d'arcade
l'année sont nommés ces personnes pour
le trophée de la meilleure en arca
[Musique]
franck gastambide et malik bentalha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
esther hanouna
hester du pdq quarté + dq du plus déçu
esther benjamin castaldi
j'ai pas trop parler de benjamin ce soir
oui c'est vrai je me sentais épargné en
fait c'est dommage parce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est un mec cool et à qui on
va parler de tout en toute décontraction
[Rires]
le laisser dans la piscine de minutes ça
de l'ajax
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais vous vous êtes calme et avec ça
mais bon vous êtes talent mais avec ça
ça va mieux deux semaines ça va mieux
mais là ça va mieux on va dire qu'il le
dit - hayes le dit - il le disait à
chaque fois à d'accord il a dansé mais
attention un pack d'accord que pour vous
c'est qui la plus grande gare car là la
meilleure dakar on va voir parce qu'il
ya eu un jury voilà je vous disais
d'action qui s'est réunie la prob la
plus grande marque à la nôtre fait d'un
meilleur d'arcade l'année c'est donc
merci
esther hanouna
alors on va lui remettre
elle n'a pas pu venir ce soir on lui
remettra à l'agent mais bon là on va pas
la peine à nous insulter
mais ça sert à rien